Congress setting to return all set to
return rather in two weeks House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi is ratcheting a pressure on
lawmakers to act on gun violence the
country's most powerful Democrat said
just yesterday she would not take no for
an answer
after two mass shootings this month but
any push for reform faces opposition in
the republican-led Senate as Congress
struggles to address the issue we wanted
to talk to people who live with the
repercussions of mass shootings every
single day and it is tough
Stephanie Melendez's father was killed
in El Paso Texas earlier this month he
was shopping with his wife and
granddaughter nine years old he pushed
them both to safety
the Reverend Sharon richer lost her
mother and two cousins in the Charleston
Church massacre Richard Martinez's only
child Chris was killed during a rampage
in Isla Vista California and Elba
Marquez Greene's little six year old
daughter on a grace was killed in the
Sandy Hook massacre in 2012 together
they all spoke of the seemingly
impossible task of moving on after
tragedy you go through periods of time
when you do feel you know the worst
thing that's ever happened to me it's
already happened to me but at the same
time I'm never gonna wreck it over it
you do know I don't want to get over it
I Kris was our only child getting over
it would seem to me to be a betrayal of
my son's memory and I don't want to get
over it how do you go on if you don't
get over it I feel like I have an
obligation as a parent to my son and
that's the work that I do to try to stop
gun violence you said Sharon before we
got started now all the shootings are
ranked in categories what do you mean so
you have the hate crime category you
have the church category you have the
school category the bottom line is dead
as a category people say it's about
Second Amendment rights the right to
bear arms I have a right to see my
daughter
enter eighth grade this fall and I don't
get to do that and I am grossly as a
mental health professional offended by
the words of our president and members
of Congress linking mental
illness to mass shootings you don't see
it as a mental health issue the vast
majority of people who are mentally ill
are not violent by a long shot
most of the gun violence that we see on
a daily basis is related more to
domestic violence and misogyny one thing
that isn't talked about a lot is
suicides families who've lost a loved
one to suicide suffer the same grief
that we do have any of you ever thought
about suicide after this yes yes I would
say in the early days it was very dark
and I hoped by me saying yes others can
be encouraged by hearing it and asked
for help they need it was like I died
Kris was everything to me it was the
center of my life I think the reason why
suicide doesn't really consider Kris
wouldn't want that you know I'm living
from I'm all that's left of my son's
memory I'm keeping him alive by being
alive you know that's that's really what
it is I want to be with her oh yeah
and I would if I could I would just say
I'm so sorry you know I'm so sorry you
didn't get what you deserved but I'll
stay here for the work that needs to be
done but I just want to be with her I so
feel that no but when you say I just
want to be with her I just wanted I just
want to be with her I have this
beautiful brown skin curly haired
singing daughter and I woke up one
morning and I didn't have her we have to
think about the people who were the
shooters in all of these cases they were
young white men in their 20s we don't
like to talk about race in a lot of
these mass shooting situations but I
think it's an important conversation to
have but Sandy Hook wasn't a race wasn't
a race it wasn't but it permeates
everything because I'll tell you an
interesting conversation my husband said
to me shortly after the shooting and he
goes you know I've spent my whole life
as a black man in America trying to
convey that I'm a safe person especially
in white environments
I look people in the eye I make sure not
to take up too much space because I'm a
six foot six inch 300-pound black man
yet a white person boy killed my
daughter and I'm not allowed to look at
him or look at others in that way right
I'm supposed to give a grace that I have
never been given as a black man in
America however I will I wish people
would give that to us and I sat in the
passenger seat and I just cried with him
Emmett Till's mother allowed people to
see what had been done to her son's body
and that changed the game in the civil
rights movement where are you all in
people seeing the damage that is caused
when your child your father your loved
one is shot Matt we need to see you
think that you can see they don't people
are visual learners people need to see
the devastation I think it's a fair
question I think it's an important one
to discuss I think how many times was on
a shot many I mean many would you have
wanted us to see that absolutely not if
this beautiful six-year-old baby her
living picture her voice her affect
everything about her alive didn't change
you her photo dead wouldn't change you
either I see if gun violence in America
does not make your heart hurt makes your
soul cry you can't feel that then you
can't feel anything it's really tough to
hear again and I was there and it's
tough to rehear it again and I think
part of the reason why they're speaking
is they said maybe if people hear our
stories they will hear us really hear us
and maybe that could lead to change and
they all said that they enjoy talking
about their loved ones it's not
something they run away from they want
to have a conversation about at the same
time you could tell it was difficult for
them at manoa there said that she does
it because there's work that still needs
to be done here for that they all feel
that is there one thing that they are
looking at
next they hope will happen what we're
gonna talk about that in the next hour
there we're talking about forgiveness
and we're talking about the possibility
of change but yeah they were still
hopeful but Tony to be honest with you
it's very very hard so far nothing has
changed and with all the shootings that
continue to happen that I'm sure just
really traumatizes them I know when we
spent actually right parkland after date
in El Paso they said they relive it
every single time this happened and what
they said - and we all sitting here
believe this it's going to happen again
it's gonna happen again you have to ask
the question who was next